if you want to understand the bind the
world faces adapting to climate change
there may be no better example than that
of the simple air conditioner
as the world warms and heat waves become
more frequent and more dangerous people
turn up the AC It's very effective at
cooling buildings and the people inside
them
but air conditioners are also power
hungry appliances with a small unit in a
single room using more electricity than
four fridges
there are currently around 1.6 billion
air conditioners in the world and that
number is expected to Triple by 2050.
where 10 new units will be installed
every second for the next three decades
at that point emissions from powering
all that air conditioning could be as
high as 2 billion tons of CO2 a year
about the same as India produces now
this is the ever accelerating feedback
loop of air conditioning higher
temperatures lead to more AC More AC
drives ever higher temperatures and
while this cycle continues people will
suffer from the ill effects of extreme
heat
it isn't only about the immediate danger
of death or illness during a heat wave
either higher temperatures can make air
quality worse and chronic conditions
flare up some studies suggest our
thinking and decision making is more
sluggish when it's hotter extreme heat
can leave people poorer too as working
hours shrink and infrastructure like
root and power become unreliable
one way to address the problem is to
Simply build a better air conditioner
there are un-backed initiatives to
improve the efficiency of EC so it uses
less power and produces fewer pollutants
but rather than betting on new or better
Tech it's also possible to change our
approach to Cooling and comfort Humanity
lived without air conditioning for much
of its history some of the most Charming
aspects of ancient cities from
Mediterranean Courtyards to narrow city
streets are actually ingeniously
engineered cooling measures that either
block out or out sunlight or use cool
stones and plants to keep the nearby Air
Pleasant throughout baking afternoons
the picturesque white villagers of
southern Spain have partly been painted
that way because light colors absorb
less Heat this often went alongside ways
of living that were adapted to the hot
weather taking a siesta meant avoiding
work during the hottest periods of the
day those who traditionally lived in the
desert were looser lighter clothing like
robes placing a white towel on the head
or neck is common in India simply
ensuring you know of a cool place to
move to during intense heat like a
basement or shaded room can also help
our predecessors also developed some
clever cooling Technologies step whales
an ancient technique that builds small
pools of water into a structure often
deep underground to cool adjacent areas
have long been common in India while
across the Middle East striking Towers
called wind catchers that direct cool
air towards buildings have been used for
centuries
more recently people have relied on
electric fans to circulate cool air
which use very little electricity
including efficient ceiling fans in
buildings would go a long way to
reducing the quantity of air
conditioning used
many of these approaches are called
passive cooling measures because they
don't consume energy but in a sense air
conditioning created a different kind of
passivity it allowed people to design
frighteningly inefficient buildings and
cities full of sealed all-glass
skyscrapers and concrete surfaces and
simply cool them down with AC reversing
this mistake for a warming World
requires an active approach designing
buildings cities and reconfiguring our
daily lives to ensure we can deal with
overheating before it happens and treat
air conditioning as a last resort
fortunately Greener more carefully built
spaces for living should have other
benefits from the savings that come with
efficient homes to the health and
well-being effects of plentiful Green
Space and safer outdoor temperatures in
towns and cities
like the climate crisis itself cooling
is a global challenge
an Oxford University study showed that
if average global temperatures missed
the 1.5 degree Target set by the Paris
agreement and hit 2 degrees Nations
already facing heat waves like those in
central Africa will see the most extreme
temperatures but northern countries
could see the biggest jump in the number
of uncomfortably hot days days when
people will need additional Cooling in
Switzerland and the UK for instance that
number will go up by 30 percent the
biggest increase globally
the researchers warned that these
countries are dangerously unprepared
with their homes and cities built with a
very different climate in mind
in the UK homes are built like
greenhouses one of the lead researchers
said
air conditioning is incredibly
convenient but it would be a disaster
for the climate if it continues to be
the worldwide remedy for Rising
temperatures the goal must be to turn
air conditioning into a technology of
Last Resort using the clever Green
Solutions of the past and adapting the
way we live and work in a hotter world
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video